depuis que les libéraux sont au pouvoir
la violence des gangs de rue a augmenté
les homicides ont augmenté de 20% cette
affirmation est elle exacte
la réponse est oui on a comptabilisé au
total 740 trois homicides l'année
dernière au pays ça représente en effet
une hausse de 20% comparativement à 2016
depuis cinq ans plus de 250 meurtres
sont commis chaque année en moyenne avec
une arme à feu c'est une augmentation de
près de 40 % comparativement à la
période 2011-2015 et meurtre par arme à
feu représente plus du tiers de tous les
homicides au pays c'est un grand parti à
cause de l'augmentation de la violence
des gangs de rue en 2019 la moitié des
homicides commis à l'aide d'une arme à
feu était très blabla des gagne on va
maintenir l'interdiction sur les armes
d'assaut il dit quelque chose dans la
plateforme que l'ordre en conseil du 20
me 2020 va être retirée puis c'est
justement cette horde l'autre qui a été
redit les armes d'assaut partout au pays
la plateforme électorale des
conservateurs mentionne clairement
l'abolition du décret adopté en mai 2020
par les libéraux qui a mené au
bannissement de 1500 armes d'assaut ils
disent qu'ils ne veulent pas renverser
cette interdiction mais plutôt réévaluer
la classification des armes
et rino tout l'avait précisé sa pensée
pendant la course à la direction du
parti conservateur lors d'une séance de
questions-réponses avec la coalition
canadienne pour les droits des armes à
feu
dans cette vidéo il déplore qu'une arme
semi automatique puisse être classé
comme une arme d'assaut en raison de sa
couleur ou de son style un gouvernement
conservateur pourrait-il retirer
certaines armes la liste établie par les
libéraux on ignore encore
[Musique]